on a l'habitude de voir les planches à
voile aller vite tenté les records de
vitesse dans les régates
seule la navigation comptes créés aux
états unis ce sont ces modèles qui sont
sortis les premiers des usines dans les
années 70 en flirtant avec l'ol font
ressortir les plumes de leur glorieux
passé
cette époque où le plaisir de la glisse
était le maître mot
oublié par le progrès technique ses
planches d'un autre temps ne sont plus
produites aujourd'hui on essaie d'en
dénicher à droite à gauche dans des vide
greniers dans des greniers chez des
particuliers et on est obligé souvent de
les retaper entièrement donc de l'est
elles sont bien abîmée ce sont des
vieilles dames qui ont presque trente
ans donc de les refaire de refaire des
pièces détachées parce que ça n'existe
plus à la base c'est un groupe d'amis
qui se réunit pour se faire plaisir
aujourd'hui ils sont une cinquantaine
grand passionné de navigation loïc était
resté à quai depuis 26 ans il s'est
remis sur l'eau par passion de ces
régates
il ya une grande évolution de la planche
c'est devient c'est devenu très
techniques de plus en plus extrêmes de
la vitesse recherche de la vitesse
là c'est différent c'est la régate faire
ce qu'ils aiment leur est gâté
faire des bords de près des triangles la
fiq eh ben c'est tout à fait adapté
quelle que soit la force du vent c'est
windsurfers navette essentiellement sur
des plans d'eau calme car la mer agitée
peut abîmer ses vieilles dames à voile
cette pratique du windsurf a disparu aux
jeux olympiques de 1992